[Music]
for some americans who have been
isolating themselves in this pandemic
their pets have become an emotional
lifeline cbs sunday morning celebrates
america's love for animals tonight in a
special prime time broadcast the pet
project
in one segment correspondent morocco
recalls the strange
and wonderful history of presidential
pets and not just horses dogs or cats
one of calvin coolidge's supporters from
mississippi decided to send the
coolidge's a thanksgiving dinner
and what he sent them was a live raccoon
andrew have you ever tried raccoon i
have not tried raccoons
i have tastes like chicken but for the
coolidges that idea was
off the table they decided well we're
going to keep her instead
so coolidge gave her a name rebecca
and then he gave her some bling so
rebecca had jewelry
yeah she had a handmade collar actually
and it said white house raccoon on it
now the press was pretty rough on
rebecca the
cleveland plain dealer called her the
most
obstreperous of all college's pets
that that is tough to be called
obstreperous
those raccoons are some mean critters mo
mo rocker we're so glad to have you with
us this morning
great to see you michelle and vlad and
tarika oh i know they're right here next
to me we're diving in because you talk
about the kennedy pets you talk about
teddy roosevelt's pets what is it about
uh presidential pets that sort of like
throws us
into curiosity
well i think like with a lot of pets
they kind of oftentimes
match the personalities of their owners
so teddy roosevelt an asthmatic
child who grows up to be our most robust
president has a one-legged rooster
and i just love to think of that
one-legged rooster just
hopping up san juan hill just not
letting anything stop him
so it's that kind of drive and that kind
of and that personality
like i said that matches its owners
nancy giles has a piece
on uh on our special tonight about how
uh pet owners oftentimes look like their
pets
like that phenomenon wow well it's
jerika here i have to ask this raccoon
really taste like chicken
first is that true it doesn't it's
it's very lean i ate it in texas okay um
and it's it's very lean it's very
healthy
um if you want it raw there is raccoon
tartare
let me know if you change your mind um
lee cowan
is uh is sitting down with michael j fox
to talk about
his service dog uh gus who has been with
him
through much of his living with
parkinson's that struggle
um seth doane is going to be talking
with bindi irwin
who i think a lot of us remember as an
eight-year-old when her father
the great steve irwin died in 2006 she's
continuing on with her
family's legacy her father's legacy um
it's pretty moving
uh mo you talked about nancy
giles package or piece of this story
where
we asked the age-old question do you
start to look like your pets or do your
pets start to look like you
what did she find out
you sort of meet in the middle like any
good marriage you kind of meet in the
middle
it's not clear all right i can't wait to
see some side-by-sides
that's the key yeah yeah absolutely
but we also have um tracy smith is going
to be doing some
experimentation with pet cloning which
should be
really interesting wow all right looking
forward to this
morocca we miss you man we miss seeing
you in the studio good to see you
i know i know once they let me out of
here i'll see you
[Laughter]
thanks bro we appreciate it you can
watch the one hour primetime special
sunday morning the pet project tonight
at 9 8 central right here on cbs